I was gum resin my name is max Tod and
welcome back to mac picl we gotta kick
the ramp out of this chair boom
Shakalaka hey boom Shakalaka boom Shaka
boom Chicka Boom Chicka Boom Chicka Boom
Boom Boom all right
I thought boom Shakalaka is like a
Swedish thing but oh [ __ ] the ball is we
kick the ball in the goal nah don't take
it up give it your heart
ah [ __ ] that doesn't weigh hitting a
girl in the face with the bomb
Jim Julie doesn't okay so firm art huh
look at this [ __ ] Aloha actually
expected that to work because this game
just make no [ __ ] sense
all right we're at in a shower which is
awkward enough as it is
but you're not supposed to bend over and
take up the soap in the shower but we're
doing it anyway and then we're giving
the soap to the bum and okay that is
fine I get it next time don't worry when
I crave your now it seems a little
spooky maybe there will be some yep
there will be zombies let's just give
him his arm back
I don't hey there sir hey you go take it
well I'm burying it then there you go
someone was not happy about that someone
came the hell is that
alright superfast boat this boat is so
fast loving music oh no time for dancing
all right let's tell you later man let's
put six bomb and anchor it drink the
bomb genius what the hell just happened
don't tell me that was a solution that
was the [ __ ] same [ __ ] this
what the hell
Oh aliens engine meltdown [ __ ] that's
not good
well you know what we do when we engine
meltdown we just get drunk with zombie
hey how you done and Pete Mack picks out
this road man no we lost our bumble well
we saw one at least I get the can I can
do it now this time we will just go to
her and touch her boobs yeah that
doesn't work
usually touching boobs all things
supermarket all right this looks so
suspicious let's just [ __ ] give it a
her there you go her boobs became bigger
whoever made this has a twisted [ __ ]
imagination I'm not gonna lie
that solved it apparently I don't think
that was a supermarket but yeah what Oh
[Music]
give me a break
come on all right uh we're fine breasts
I got this one it's 50 pies logic we
gotta adapt so let's just click on the
grace
[Music]
ah God was not happy about that so we
died anyway
back in space this time we will not
urinate on his floor we will just put
this over here hey what's that let's put
them in here now it's cold there right
now still lick bugs ok this time we will
just go to the girl and take off her
shorts we can honestly you can't wear
those shorts [ __ ] it let's take the bomb
and give it to her whoa well that one
actually made sense that was a nice
throw mcpixel ok let's take the soap and
put it on the dynamite and does not work
take his arm and then God will take it
and be like what a hell up Jania spits
strikes again don't worry about it let's
see if we can get three of them ok this
time we will give it to the window or
this or this or this or just drink it
ourself
earlier didn't I
okay so you're dirty
why am I doing this it's like oh we're
about to die let's rub this man with
soap okay I think the beer is just a
decoy let's just go to the hem and kick
in
ah [ __ ] pixel door 1964 ready load space
what is he doing don't play games do the
dynamite explode inside his [ __ ] is
that what I just witnessed holy [ __ ]
alright there's a green button here that
looks pretty good let's see what we can
do about it
this is difficult no I don't I don't
mean to do that this is the last one we
got us we got
no it's not good name
[Music]
loading space invaders clearly missing
something here what
there's something here and see that
let's get drunk and pizza yes yeah smack
fix a nice job P on there overload what
is this I don't want to return take me
home Axl back too many all right we have
all right I guess we should finish off
there once on the second floor because
we never I don't know if I did that did
I do it I did do it I'm an idiot all
right that means we can start a new one
which is good will you get the senior
stuff let's go in there chapter 2 run
three boom casting gotta love the music
it's so [ __ ] annoying and awesome at
the same time that is me if I were mean
the evil I guess
a stick is crown ah I think we found the
bomb there that's Super Mario are you
Super Mario what
but today dude oh [ __ ] he's asleep and
there's a crack in the wall let's take
the bomb what I need to do that what
usually the reference to something but
I'm really bad at references you can
bros can tell me in the comments if I'm
missing any references oh no I thought
that was a solution come on Mac pixel
this is fun cool
cool I'm glad we're having fun I hate
clowns so we're gonna go for the sugar
cone things and put it in his face it's
what you get for being a kid why did you
have to do that mega satan is that what
it says
Oh wearing a heart harder yes
head-banging next to chicken why not why
the [ __ ] not
sorry chicken but your life would be
more valuable this way now it's a
solution hitting the bomb with the
chicken I take it thank you
there's a thing to pull here let's do it
and now that the anchor strikes again
okay
Super Mario wants a rocket in between
her boobs Mac pixel if it doesn't work
the first time don't bother with the
other fight God IV about pixel okay
let's take the computer
and just turn it up Jania good job
mcpixel
[Music]
okay this time we take the rock and
hahaha hello all just rolls with it I'm
okay
this time we will take balloon oh that's
a big I mean my pixel little dice we do
that there's something over here and see
that it's underwear [ __ ] really
I bet it's ours how did I know that I
mean of course I did so obvious how
could I not see that all right let's
give it to Mario all right yeah let's
hit his belly he's always got it in his
belly
nope that my well [ __ ] there's got to be
something about this dude oh we're
picking them up he's still asleep hey
dude yeah why would that help anyone
okay this time we will just throw it at
the thing
yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] dead it might be a shell
[Music]
okay I think I have time to finish be
okay slit its throat good why is the
bump I did not work [ __ ] him what is up
with that dude
like why is he there let's give the
rocket to him and he's probably gonna do
some way [ __ ] with Mario no no that was
a solution now I can't the installation
all right no we already did that this
time we take the sugar cone and we give
it to this dude here you go man take it
ha ha yeah
oh that I just iam bad bad heart okay
and then we put him on the bomb hey toad
wake up okay I'll take that I don't know
what that was I think she'll all right
that's it for me breasts I'm gonna go
pack up my chin but anyway like and
favorite if you enjoyed it subscribe it
come abroad today and yeah
[Music]
oh yeah you like that by you like that
British and whadda what right you're so
good I asked you better believe I'm good
at it
[Applause]
[Music]